good evening from London welcome to
Piers Morgan on sensor King Charles III
has been diagnosed with cancer the king
told close family members including his
sons Prince William and Prince Harry and
his three siblings the announcement was
made to the British public at 6 PM this
evening and shocked the world Prince
Harry the Duke of susex has told friends
he's flying into the UK over the next
few days to see his father who he's
already spoken to over the phone the
type of cancer has not been revealed but
we do know from the palace it is not
prostate cancer but the cancer was
discovered during the king's recent
treatment for an enar prostate well
Bucky and Palace said tonight the king
began regular treatments as an
outpatient on Monday he was last seen
publicly as recently as Sunday attending
church in Norfolk with his wife Queen
Camila he remains the head of state he
will undertake basic state duties from
the palace including his weekly meeting
with the Prime Minister but public
engagements have all been postponed for
the duration of his treatment it's
unclear if you'll be able to undertake
major International trips to Canada and
New Zealand planned over the coming
months well reaction as you'd expect is
pouring in from around the world here
prime minister Rishi sunak and sakir
starm have wished him a speedy recovery
in United States Donald Trump just
posted he's a wonderful man who I got to
know well during my presidency and we
all pray that he has a fast and full
recovery President Joe Biden said he's
concerned and hope to talk to him
soon you have a message for King Charles
message for King char to call concerned
about him just heard his diagnosis but
I'll be talking to him got wrong what
joining me now is talk tov's Royal
editor Sarah Houston Royal biographer
Tom bow Fox News contributor Mark
seagull and former editor of the Sunday
Times Andrew Neil okay well Sarah let's
start with you just on this breaking
news I got told just after five o'clock
there's a massive statement coming from
Buckingham Palace about King Charles and
we think it's cancer uh and I read the
statement maybe just a few minutes
before it it went out it was shocking I
mean you don't read this kind of thing
about a senior member of the royal
family and yet it comes just after the
previous Health statements about both
Charles having his his prostate
operation which was for a benign
situation and for Kate the Princess of
Wales a lot of Health stories about the
ruls this is it appears to be by far the
most serious yes and you're right it it
has come as a shock because we know the
king went into hospital for a planned
procedure on uh an enlarged Pro prate a
benign uh enlarged prostate we were told
we thought that that was very typical
for a man of his age and we were told
that he'd put that diagnosis out there
because he wanted to raise awareness he
did have to stay in the hospital a
little bit longer than we had initially
thought he was in for three nights he
had regular visits from Queen Camila
during that period and it was during
that procedure that an area of concern
was noticed some I wonder about the
timing because I'm told by people close
to to the Royals that
as as late as like two days ago
yesterday everything seemed fine and it
seems to me what maybe more likely maybe
Dr Mar seagel can tell us this is that
they took some of his prostate away for
further examination in that operation he
had and then something nasty turned up
which was nothing to do with a prostate
but it revealed another cancer in his
body and I think that this has come as a
shock to everybody from what I can tell
even senior member of the Royal Family
had no idea this was coming absolutely
and we saw the king and the queen uh at
Sandringham yesterday uh we do
understand that they knew last week uh
Queen Camila opened a Maggie's Cancer
Care Center and we told that she did
that knowing the diagnosis we think we
think that she knew by that point we my
understanding is that she carried on
with that engagement and it will have
taken on and added significance of
course uh for her we know that the king
told his siblings uh an Edward and Drew
we don't know but before this was made
public and SP to both sons okay so Tom I
think this has all happened pretty
quickly and that says to me this has
come as a big shock uh and the the royal
family already reeling from the deaths
of Prince Phillip from her majesty the
queen from the double Health blow that
we heard several weeks ago of Charles
and and Kate and now this that our new
monar has cancer well it does come as a
shock but on the other hand I must tell
you that before Christmas someone nebor
of his in high gr did tell me that the
king wasn't well and also warned that
Queen Camila is not perfect health
either so I think that although it seems
like it's a great shock tonight to us I
think this has been coming for some time
well just bringing Andrew Neil Andrew
you were one of the great newspaper
editors this is one of those stories
isn't it where it breaks at six o'cl at
night and everyone is scrambling I'd
imagine the papers will be absolutely
full of this tomorrow what do you what
do you make of this and in particular
the wording of the palace statement
which I I got to say with my own former
newspaper editor haton I think this
looks quite a serious
situation well they told us more than
they usually do in these circumstances
they haven't told us anything like the
full picture we don't know what kind of
cancer it is but they told us more than
they usually do they told us more than
they did when the queen was getting
seriously unwell it is a huge story I've
been watching the American Network it's
the lead story in every American News
Network to t i I've been watching French
and German TV is the lead story there as
well it's the lead story in every major
Network I would guess around the world
and there will be a Temptation for
journalists to make Harry the story
because he's now going to be flying back
and we hope that uh at times of Crisis
or this is a crisis for the royal family
it can bring families together but I
hope we don't make Harry the story the
story is the king yeah um the story is
the queen and Prince William uh and his
wife Kate who will have to step up to
the plate particularly when Kate gets
better to fill in uh some of the gaps
that Charles will leave behind the
important matter is the continuity of
the British state in these circumstances
and the core of the British state has a
thousand years of experience in dealing
with these things not many countries
that can say they've got a thousand
years of experience and I'm encouraged
by the fact that the king will still
carry out a lot of functions in private
including the privy Council and meeting
the Prime Minister and his red boxes
that it's not been thought necessary to
create a council of state that would
take over the functions the
Constitutional functions of the Monarch
and I think when you add all that
together that's encouraging the
continuity will continue and it's very
important to us in an election year yes
because the purpose of the monarchy is
to provide continuity and stability
regardless of what's happening in
politics and having an election this
year and it's very important that the
monarchy plays that role above politics
for the country as a whole yeah very
very good point Andrew we've got Roy
nicker who's the Royal correspondent for
the Sunday Times Andrew's old paper
before I come to you Roy I want to read
the Bucking and Palace statement in full
and then get your reaction to this it
says during the king's recent Hospital
procedure for benign prostate
enlargement a separate issue of concern
was noted subsequent diagnostic tests
have identified a for of cancer his
majesty has today commenced to schedule
regular treatments during which time
he's been advised by doctors to postpone
public facing duties throughout this
period his majesty will continue to
undertake State business and official
paperwork as usual the king is grateful
to his medical team for their Swift
Intervention which was made possible
thanks to his recent Hospital procedure
he remains wholly pos positive about his
treatment and looks forward to returning
to full public duty as soon as possible
his majesty has chosen to share his
diagnosis to prevent speculation and in
the hope it may assist public
understanding for all those around the
world affected by cancer so Roya I mean
that was a bombshell statement and as
always with royal statements you kind of
look for the the devil in the detail if
you like and I got to say I like I said
I think this is quite a serious
situation which has emerged from a not
so serious situation which was the
procedure for the benign prostate
enlargement this is clearly a separate
and and is a cancer two it's a different
thing altogether and it's more
serious you can't peer um detract from
the fact that cancer is a very serious
diagnosis whatever form it is and we
don't know what form it is yet um we're
told you know he may choose to share
more uh information down the line during
his treatment but just to your point
about you know always unpicking
statements from the palace I have to say
I actually looked at that statement and
some of the guidance that we've had
tonight some background guidance we've
had from um The Palace particularly the
items about no councils of State being
needed so we are not going to see Prince
William or Prince Edward or an stepping
in constitutionally for the king it's
been made very clear quite sort of
firmly that constitutionally at the
moment nothing has changed the king is
going to keep doing his Affairs of state
has read boxes we just won't see him in
public so much so yes it's very serious
he's got cancer but at the same time
that phrase you know he is wholly
positive about his treatment and that he
is still doing Affairs of State I that
is actually quite a hopeful sign yeah
but for a new king of less than a year
to no longer be doing any engagements in
front of the public I I just think you
know knowing Charles uh as I have for a
long time not not particularly closely
but having followed his his life this is
a tough guy a very thick guy used to
yumping around the highlands and leading
a very fit active life for him to
basically Retreat from public life in
the way that he is is yes he may be
saying he's holy positive I wouldn't
expect anything else but I I I think
this must be a serious situation because
he he's counseling all public
engagements apparently while he
undergoes his
treatment I mean there's no doubt that
you know cancer is serious for anyone
but I think in terms of sort of
retreating from public view when you
know depending on what his treatment
involves the palace and the royal family
and the King himself will want to
minimize you know the health risk to him
in terms of it it's one thing to meet
with the Prime Minister and have an
audience with him as we're told
hopefully he will continue to do that
and meet with the privy Council it's
it's another thing to you know be at a
buck and Palace reception with 300
people in the room which I think is why
you know ering on the side of caution
for the head of state for our Monarch
he's with withdrawn but of course you
know you cannot shy away from the fact
that the king as you say just year and a
half into his Reign is having to
withdraw from public life temporarily we
hope is a huge blow to him a huge blow
to his Reign it's going to be a big
challenge for him and the family to
Rally around yeah uh Tom the subplot
here um and Andrew Neil was quite right
that shouldn't be the story but it's
interesting that as obviously this
massive ongoing Rift with Prince Harry
and his father but we've been told from
Friends of Prince Harry that he's
planning to fly from California to see
his father which will be the nearest
thing to a reproach more we've seen you
do see this with families when they're
Waring is a dramatic event like this uh
can bring people together what do you
make of that well I think that RMA is
fitting on the other hand I'm very
suspicious because as we've discussed
often here um Harry's agenda has been so
antim monarchist has been so
disrespectful of the king and the Queen
and of course of his brother that uh for
him suddenly to turn up in London not
having expressed any uh concern for his
father when he heard originally about
the prostrate problem which is two weeks
ago that's been a period of Silence so
suddenly he's flying in I think it's
seen two things not the r only but also
how serious it is I don't think it is a
benign issue at all I think you're quite
right that there is a there is a mini
crisis happening yeah and Andrew Neil if
I could come back to you uh for a moment
you know we've covered the Royals for
many many decades and they've always
been the biggest story in town and like
you say the news of the king's diagnosis
is leading the news around the world not
least in America um where it's huge I've
had loads of calls and people wanting
interviews about this already so you can
see you can see how big a story this is
but does it also point to the fragility
of our royal family right now we've lost
the great matriarch in the queen we lost
the great patriarch in Prince Phillip
we've now got the Princess of Wales
who's having months off uh work because
of uh we don't know what what it was
that she had but it was obviously pretty
serious uh we've got Charles now the new
monarch who has cancer you know if you
look at the sort of top the top list
list of Royals this is a this is a big
moment isn't it I mean this is a like I
say this this points to the fragility of
the whole
thing it's come at a bad time of course
cancer diagnosis has never come at a
good time but it with the all family
we've gone from Surplus to famine uh
very very quickly I mean a lot of people
would say I don't mind uh the king or
the queen I don't mind the very top rows
but I don't like all these Hangers On
well a lot of the so my mother used to
call them hang on well these kind of
Royals seem to have stopped hanging on
they've disappeared now prince Andrew is
no longer in in the game Prince Harry
CED himself out along with Megan the
Princess of Wales has not been well so
William has refused himself uh to we are
now have a royal family that's pretty
short-handed and of course this will put
huge strain on the queen at a very
difficult time for her but also more
strain on William who was hoping to step
back and look after his wife he is now
under pressure and will succumb to that
pressure to get back into public life
and pick up some of these public
engagements so it's um the productivity
of the remaining senior members of the
royal family who are able to do what
royal should be doing not many of them
anymore that will have to increase in
the weeks and months ahead and I think
the other thing to look for look this is
just a breaking story because as you
know we do not know what kind of cancer
it is though all cancer is scary and bad
we do not know the treatment that the
king is getting or what impact the
treatment will have on the king himself
which I think is very important so I
think in the days and probably the weeks
ahead we'll get a better idea of whether
the kick whether the king will be able
to carry on in private with his
important duties and eventually come
back to public life or whether it's so
serious that even in private his duties
are now hard to to carry out that to my
mind is the thing to look for in the
weeks yeah I completely agree Sarah I
mean Andrew is so right isn't it that
the number of top people in the royal
family available to do the functional
work of the royal family which is huge I
mean they all do hundreds of Royal
engagements a year these can be big ones
small ones but they're serving the
people that's the deal the contract with
the British public there aren't many of
them at the moment able to actually work
no and and and those that are working
already have packed schedules Princess
Anne for example has an incredibly busy
Di and and the king is going to be
relying on his sister now also on uh
Sophie The Duchess of Edinburgh on
Edward the the Duke of Edinburgh and
Prince William but as Andrew was saying
Prince William was hoping to take some
time out to be looking after his wife
and children next week is half term the
children will be home from school Kate
not really able uh to be carrying on as
normal but we had the announcement today
and I think the timing of that was
significant and choreographed that he's
back to public duties on Wednesday he's
going to be hosting an investure at wins
a castle he's got an event on Wednesday
he needs to be seen because as the late
Queen used to say you know the all
family need to be seen to remembering
William would be very worried about his
wife and worried about his father and
Camila will be absolutely you know
heartbroken about what's going on with
Charles the great love of her life never
Mount the public duty stuff she's going
to carry on with her duties there
presumably some of them will have to
pick up some of the Kings at some stage
of his carries on but she'll also have
in her own world this is a devastating
moment sometimes it's easy forget be
supporting him through his treatment as
well because we don't know what impact
it's going to have on him you talked
about reading line between the lines of
the statements uh now we look back on
some of the words that Camila has said
over the past couple of weeks initially
when she was asked she said he was doing
fine last week she said he's doing his
best yes uh when she was asked how he
was and that takes on a greater
significance now we know what has been
going on okay U Andrew Neil and Roy nck
thank you both very much indeed
uh